[Música]
no siempre fui tan grandote como me ven
ahora alguna vez soy más chiquito cuando
era más chiquito más o menos de tamaño
tenía miedos por supuesto bueno ahora
también pero en esa época tenía miedos
distintos los que tengo ahora que tenía
un miedo que era bastante particular que
es que me daba miedo quedarme dormido
porque cuando uno duerme la consciencia
desaparece miami esa desaparición
me hacía sospechar que la consciencia
podía hacer algo frágil
quien te garantiza que cuando te vas a
dormir te vas a despertar a la mañana
cimiento que tu conciencia va a volver
yo me hacía esas preguntas y obviamente
después terminaba haciendo cosas como
caminar descalzo por mi casa toda la
noche con tal de no quedarme dormido
hoy muchos años después yo soy
científico más precisamente soy un
neurocientífico grandote
y mi trabajo es entender cómo el cerebro
genera la conciencia
qué es la conciencia bueno a veces las
cosas que no son más inmediatas son las
más difíciles de entender y no hay nada
que sea más inmediato que nuestra propia
conciencia pero una analogía que ayuda a
pensar la conciencia es imaginarnos
sentados en un teatro y en ese teatro se
representa la obra más compleja y más
real que existe la obra que contiene
todas las imágenes que vemos todos los
sonidos que escuchamos todas las
emociones que sentimos lo que vemos en
esa obra es lo que vemos lo que
escuchamos en esta obra es lo que
escuchamos y lo que sentimos en esa obra
lo que la obra nos hace sentir es lo que
sentimos y lo que se representa en la
obra son los contenidos de nuestra
conciencia
y la obra es la consciencia misma cuando
se apagan las luces que iluminan el
escenario cuando se representa la obra
la conciencia también se apaga
la conciencia desaparece
pero por suerte por supuesto cuando se
vuelven a encender las luces que
iluminan el escenario la conciencia se
vuelve a encender la conciencia vuelve a
aparecer
en mi trabajo usé distintas herramientas
para entender qué pasa en el cerebro
cuando la conciencia desaparece una de
esas herramientas es justamente eso que
me daba miedo cuando era chico el sueño
profundo pero también investigue
personas bajo anestesia general o
pacientes en un estado de coma que son
todas condiciones en las cuales las
luces que iluminan la obra la
consciencia se apagan
y el escenario donde se representa esa
obra que contiene todo lo que sentimos
está por supuesto dentro del cerebro
está en un conjunto de regiones que se
llaman red frontal parietal se llaman
así porque está más o menos dentro del
cráneo por encima de los ojos frontal y
por encima de las orejas por el costado
parietal nosotros somos conscientes de
algo únicamente en la medida que la
información sobre ese algo accede a las
neuronas de la red frontal parietal y
desde ahí puede acceder a todo el
cerebro explota y accede todo el cerebro
y lo que pasa es que en condiciones como
el sueño profundo
o condiciones como la anestesia o el
coma la red frontal parietal se apaga
deja cómo se apagan las luces que
iluminan el escenario donde se
representa esa obra
entonces pensando en estas cosas hace
algunos años me empecé a dar una
pregunta que si iba a cambiar mi carrera
pero sobre todo iba a cambiar también mi
manera de entender el mundo y entenderme
a mí mismo y la pregunta
es la siguiente qué pasa si la red
frontal parietal no solamente no se
apaga sino que se enciende con una
actividad todavía mayor a la normal con
una actividad todavía mayor a la que
tenemos todos nosotros acá y ahora por
ejemplo conscientes y despiertos
qué pasa si ocurre lo opuesto a lo que
pasa cuando nos quedamos dormidos en la
inconsciencia
bueno en toda obra de teatro pasan un
montón de cosas y en realidad alguno no
las ve en el escenario es lo que pasa
tras bambalinas todo el trabajo para la
puesta en escena y cuando uno va al
teatro aún con las luces iluminan el
escenario encendidas uno nunca ve esas
cosas pero están ahí entonces la
pregunta que yo me había hecho es la
siguiente qué pasa si no solamente no
apagamos las luces que iluminan el
escenario sino que las encendemos una
intensidad tan pero tan grande que hasta
la puesta en escena hasta todo lo que
ocurre tras bambalinas no solamente se
vuelve visible sino que se vuelve hasta
imposible de no ver
claramente herramientas como el sueño
profundo o la anestesia que apagan las
luces la conciencia no me iban a servir
para responder esta pregunta yo
necesitaba una herramienta diferente una
herramienta específica para manifestar
con más intensidad todas esas cosas que
ocurren en el cerebro en la mente
incluso las que están ahí ocultas las
bambalinas y la herramienta que yo
necesitaba era un manifestador de mentes
y un manifestador de mentes nos suena a
la clase de herramientas que uno va a
comprar una ferretería cualquiera
pero me enteré que los manifestadores
dementes existen que son tan reales como
el sueño profundo o la anestesia solo
que si nunca escucharon hablar de los
manifestadores de mentes es porque el
nombre que tienen en realidad está en
griego se llaman psicodélicos en griego
chico significamente de lo que significa
manifestar
manifestadores de méndez los
psicodélicos son moléculas
y algunas son naturales y están en
cactus como la mescalina o en hongos
como la psilocibina y otras son
sintéticas hechas por el hombre como en
lcd
y generan cambios muy intensos en
nuestra percepción del mundo en nuestras
emociones pero también en nuestra
percepción de nosotros mismos y sobre
todo de la relación que tenemos con todo
lo que nos rodean y son cambios que
generan interfiriendo en las
conversaciones químicas que entablan las
neuronas de nuestro cerebro para
comunicarse entre sí
y en nuestras investigaciones aprendimos
de hecho que esas neuronas están
principalmente en la red frontal
parietal del cerebro y lo que hacen los
psicodélicos es encender exageradamente
la actividad de la red frontal parietal
del cerebro
podríamos decir que hacen de hecho lo
opuesto al sueño profundo oa la
anestesia o lo que vemos en un estado de
coma actualmente con mi laboratorio de
la universidad de buenos aires estamos
realizando el primer estudio sobre los
efectos de un psicodélico natural la
historia argentina
nos interesa estudiar qué ocurre en el
cerebro humano cuando eso pasa pero
también qué es lo que le ocurre a la
persona qué es lo que la persona siente
y uno de nuestros sujetos experimentales
expresó eso quizás mucho mejor de lo que
yo lo podría expresar sentado todavía
con un montón de cables y electrodos
pegados a su cabeza que son los pulsamos
justamente para medir la actividad de su
cerebro nos miró y nos dijo que su
experiencia visual fue tan abrumadora
tan intensa que sintió que tuvo que
abrir los ojos para dejar de ver
abrir los ojos para dejar de dar
los psicodélicos también se están
investigando como medicinas como terapia
para ayudar a pacientes con depresión o
con la ansiedad que puede generar algo
tan terrible como un diagnóstico de
cáncer los resultados hasta ahora son
muy positivos y la evidencia nos dice
los pacientes que más se benefician de
los psicodélicos como terapias son los
que sienten que desaparece esa frontera
que separa a su propio cuerpo y ellos
mismos de todas las demás cosas se
sienten en todas las cosas ellos ya no
están sentados en una butaca viendo la
obra sino que las luces también los
iluminan y entienden entonces que ellos
y nosotros también
en realidad están y estamos dentro de la
obra misma
pero
la misma experiencia sobre todo sin
supervisión adecuada puede generar un
estado de mucha ansiedad y angustia
lo cual no es extraño si entendemos una
medicina se receta para alguien que la
necesita y consumirla o suministrar la
afuera de este contexto
si es ilegal pero sobre todo es
irresponsable y necesitamos
responsabilidad porque dije estamos
realizando el primer estudio de la
historia del país con psicodélicos pero
estamos en el año 2019
entonces si realmente me creen
y son herramientas tan útiles porque
nadie las investiga antes bueno en
realidad en los años 50 y 60
eeuu los psicodélicos investigaron muy
intensamente pero en un momento pasó
algo que no tendría que haber pasado es
que los psicodélicos salieron de los
laboratorios y salieron de los
hospitales y fueron consumidos
masivamente y de formas inapropiadas
lógicamente se previeron
y por eso que hoy es extremadamente
difícil hacer investigación científica
con psicodélicos esta situación tiene
que cambiar déjennos hacer investigación
científica con psicodélicos esto no se
trata del consumo se trata de
conocimiento se trata de ciencia y se
trata de medicina
[Música]
comprendemos que hay una responsabilidad
asociada a eso y no es automático en los
próximos 10 años
si esto pasa vamos a poder beneficiarnos
enormemente de los psicodélicos como
herramientas para entender la mente como
medicina para ayudar a quienes realmente
lo necesitan pero que eso pase en los
próximos 10 años depende de no repetir
todos esos errores del pasado depende
esencialmente de que esta vez sea
diferente
yo
personalmente hoy ya me siento diferente
porque a mi estas preguntas estas nuevas
posibilidades a mí me apasionan tanto
ellos sueño con estas cosas entonces hoy
yo me voy a dormir a la noche tan pero
tan entusiasmado que es por eso que ya
ni siquiera se me ocurre pensar si me
voy a despertar o no a la mañana
haciendo
[Aplausos]
[Música]